jennifer lee morgan is the special envoy
for international climate action from
the german government you might know her
as the head of greenpeace international
it's the first time here in washington
in her new role just ahead of the g7
summit jennifer thank you so much for
making time for deutsche welle great to
see you
you started with high hopes to push
forward a climate-oriented foreign
policy
what is left of that in the time of war
there's still a lot left in a time of
war i mean obviously
the russian aggression and working for
peace is a top priority but this war
has taught us how dangerous it is to be
so dependent on fossil fuels
and so
we are working very hard to
phase out of course russian fossil fuels
but also all fossil fuels and to do that
we're accelerating our energy
transformation to renewable energy and
energy efficiency and working around the
world to get others to do the same and
that's a big part of international
climate politics and policy
you here in washington obviously the
biden administration also started really
strong on fighting the
climate catastrophe they even had a
climate tsar or put a climate star
in place how did the war in ukraine
change the whole discussion here in the
united states when it comes to renewable
energy well i think it's it's
interesting i think in the united states
on the one hand
you know as in germany one sees okay
with renewable energy um you're quite
independent actually from others but the
united states
has a lot of fossil fuels
and i think what's happened here is that
instead of you know moving more quickly
i mean the president is trying to move
quickly to renewable energy you see the
very large interests of fossil fuels
working now in this moment of disruption
to try and use it
to get more fossil fuels out of the
ground and build long-term fossil fuel
infrastructure and that's really the
crossroads that we're in right now so do
countries like the united states and
germany and europe we're going in that
direction
move more into
secure renewable energy or do they lock
in long-term fossil fuels and obviously
in washington there's a lot of interests
working to lock in long-term fossil
fuels do you have a conversation with
with government with the government here
i think that the president from
everything i understand remains
very committed on climate change and is
trying to get something done
uh through congress
on climate and renewable energy
but obviously the pressures are huge
it's hugely concerning at the same time
if the united states moves more into
fossil fuel exploration when we know and
scientists tell us that that's actually
what we cannot do
at this moment
it requires just tremendous
leadership
but i also have met with many here civil
society groups think tanks
companies as well
who want to move in and are building the
base of support for a cleaner energy
future
but that's this is this crossroads that
we're in right now but yeah i'm am i
worried absolutely
is there any chance that europe
or germany and europe are getting
prepared
for a united states which is kind of
leaving
the climate commitment again well i
think you know we've been there once
and uh it was uh very detrimental i
think on the one hand
on the global level but i think what we
learned through
the years when
president trump was in office who was a
climate denier was how much we can work
with other actors
so working with mayors working with
those that want to move forward
and having exchanges that are happening
between our countries ahead of the g7
meeting in germany
many people demand that germany and
other rich countries do more to support
the global south in moving
towards renewable energy what can we
expect from germany to do first we need
to all do more we all agreed in glasgow
to
increase our ambition
more renewable energy bringing in
methane other greenhouse gases
so we
pledged to do that and that obviously is
a big signal to other countries
major emerging economies that they need
to do the same
and for developing countries we've
committed to really move forward on our
climate finance to meet the commitments
that we have made which
are still outstanding which is of great
concern to developing countries
but also to double our funding for
adaptation
and to really start engaging on these
issues of loss and damage you know what
happens
what happens when uh an island
loses
its all its home the g7 has committed to
really move forward actively on that
conversation and send the signal that
we're going to stand in solidarity but
that would be my question sending out a
signal is nice talking about it is
wonderful
kind of paying condolences if someone
dies
or hundreds or thousands of people are
dying in floods and droughts all around
the world but what precisely
is going is germany going to suggest
there in the g7
so i think germany
specifically is looking at a few things
so first of all
indeed you know
saying that we are going to be
supporting
countries in their
transition away from coal
or looking to do that um we're in
negotiations with a number of countries
right now from the global south on how
to do that
so i think how we support those
countries is is a topic right now that's
being uh negotiated
i think the other thing uh is how we can
be driving the decarbonization of the
industrial sector so steel cement etc
and the foundation um of interest of a
climate club or a group of countries
that are moving forward not only the g7
countries but offering a hand also
obviously to developing countries that
want to join and and looking to see how
we can support them
uh in doing that
and then really um committing to double
down on these financial commitments so
it's not just a signal it's actually
okay how are we going to meet that 100
billion
uh commitment that was made so long ago
by developed country so this you would
you say is still a top priority for the
german government for the g7 summit yes
absolutely i think the climate issue the
climate crisis is a top priority for the
g7
obviously other issues around food
security uh obviously the the russian
aggression and and how we're working
together to support ukraine uh towards
peace are key issues but climate is
still at that top table
jennifer morgan how does it make you
feel when you see a green energy
minister talking about going back to
coal
and maybe even going back to nuclear
energy it may how it makes me feel
i think i'd start with
how i feel when he talks about
the importance of accelerating the
energy transition the 500 page bill
that's in front of the parliament to do
that all of the very detailed measures
that we can meet an 80 renewable energy
target by 2030
and i think um
i think his honesty about the fact that
this is a bitter pill but that we have
to
basically make sure that we have the
ability to
have
our our citizens
safe and secure moving in the coming
months
is is understandable i think it's
responsible but also you know his
commitment to continue uh our commitment
to phase out coal
uh by you know aiming for that 2030 goal
that makes me feel
as if we are being responsible that we
are sticking with our climate goals
which is one of my main messages here in
the united states
but
that hasn't gone away but that we also
have
we are in an acute extreme situation
that we need to negotiate around and
therefore we have in this short time
period
to look at how we make sure that we are
energy secure how much is the former
government
the american administration to be blamed
for that situation germany's in
well i think certainly we've learned uh
that having such a high dependency uh on
one country
for so much of our energy
is not good policy making uh it has set
up
immense vulnerabilities
so now this government is
working to change that and also to learn
from it that we we just can't be that
that dependent uh we're taking that
responsibility very seriously while also
keeping climate at the top of our agenda
uh but um no it wasn't an easy situation
to come into jennifer morgan you took
the plunge from activism to policy
to a policy maker is this the way to go
from calling
for responsibility to actually taking
responsibility
well i think
i think when an opportunity arises as an
activist and i still consider myself i
call myself i guess an activist diplomat
now
uh to come in and work for someone like
uh minister barabak to make change in
the world
and be a decision maker that's something
that uh an opportunity that you just
have to jump into
and i'm honored to be here i'm trying to
do my best to try and move us forward
and make the decisions that will propel
us into a zero-carbon world last
question what has been the most painful
part from shifting from activism into
politics
when you make a shift like this from
kind of outside
uh being an activist into being a
decision maker i think
i don't know if i would call it painful
but i think that the intensity of the
responsibility
um
is is greater
at greenpeace when i led greenpeace and
worked for other ngos i always felt a
responsibility to our supporters of
course who funded us to do things but as
a member of a government really making
decisions i feel a much greater sense of
responsibility
to the tasks that i've been given and to
the people who i'm you know representing
and that's um
that i carry with me every day
jennifer lee morgan thank you so much
for your time and let's keep this
conversation going we'd love to thank
you so much